all right guys
bang bang i've got patrick here with me
thank you so much for doing this man
thanks for having me on absolutely let's
just jump right into
city coins uh i think this is kind of a
fascinating idea that uh you've been
working on
what exactly is a city coin
the city coins allow you to put a city
into your portfolio
so when you support a city by buying its
city coin or mining its city
you're directly contributing to um
essentially some yield
that the city themselves is earning
so um what citycoins uh can do
is a few functions so you can program
city coins
like developers can use them um you can
mine them
and then you can stack them so the
process of mining a city coin
is the process of sending a base
currency
into the city coin smart contract for
that specific city
and um competing to mint new city coins
now this the base currency that's being
forwarded into it
gets diverted to uh two areas
thirty percent of it goes directly to a
reserved wallet that a city
can claim custody of and 70 of it goes
directly to
everyone else that is locking up their
city coins
uh via this this concept called stacking
and so um so that's the basic gist and
we think that this is going to
create a completely new dynamic between
uh government officials and the markets
got it and so right now when you think
about kind of the technical architecture
of this
uh you guys are using the bitcoin
blockchain
for security and kind of merge mining
stuff in or how
exactly does it work uh leveraging the
the bitcoin blockchain
yeah so um we're actually we're actually
just sort of generalizing
what the stacks blockchain is already
doing uh by
recycling bitcoin as uh kind of like a
crystallized proof of work
and forwarding that into the stacks
blockchain to secure the sax blockchain
so what i described with how you mine
city coins
you do the same thing with uh the stacks
blockchain as well so
you know people compete to get uh new
new stacks by forwarding bitcoin and
that secures
uh the network and so it's like a race
essentially see who can
afford the most and you know your
chances of winning is
uh sort of weighted based on how much
you've contributed
um so it's pretty green like you don't
have to um
you don't have to create your own proof
of work and you don't have to rely on
you know something that we believe is
less secure which is proof of stake
and and so essentially what we're doing
there is we're saying okay
um if this works for the stacks
blockchain well it can work for chains
above the sacs blockchain
in this case the whole city coin
ecosystem so
what we're doing is we're actually using
stocks
as the base currency to forward in to
the city coins
uh smart contract to mint new city coins
just like
stocks requires bitcoin to mint uh new
stacks got it and so it let's just fast
forward
25 years right and kind of go to the
ultra bowl case for this
uh it works and let's pick a specific
city
uh anywhere in the world that ends up
doing this who is kind of the customer
or the users when you think of this
do you think of the government the local
government as the customer do you think
of
uh citizens in that uh local ecosystem
as the customer is there
investors like just walk me through
first kind of structurally
how you think about who this is serving
and then we can kind of talk about what
that would look like if it works
yeah sure so just to sort of take a step
back i think
every startup city is going to have its
own city coin it's almost like every
company has its own cap table and that's
how you organize
people to um you know do work in success
of the company's mission
i think that's going to happen with
cities and and
you can imagine like cities like
bangalore india miami florida
new york city dubai uh
singapore all having their own city
coins and even small cities like
maybe even bitcoin beach right um can
have its own city coin like dollar sign
beach
um and i think uh what's going like
essentially there are there are you know
two and potentially three
uh customers so the first customer is
the city government
and i'll walk through kind of like why
they're a customer so the city
government is given this sacrosanct
reserve wall that they can claim and no
one else but then can claim
and and the economics are such that when
the
uh when the if the market cap for that
that city's coin
is at like a billion dollars that city
is earning like 50 million dollars per
year
that's enough to like wipe out municipal
debt servicing that's enough to
recruit new crypto startups into their
into their uh
into their um sort of municipality
and i think what's going to happen is
you're going to see this sort of
archetype
of ceo of the city emerging
for which like you know a mayor like
mary suarez is really kind of one of the
first
and so what they're going to do i
believe is i believe
the best sort of city cities will
operate like startups essentially
they'll use their funds to recruit new
founders
they'll uh who could also add more
utility to their own city coin
uh who can build apps around it or just
apps generally in the crypto space
that you know um that that exists and
they they get tax revenue um but
um you can imagine also world where like
these city coins become even more
valuable than a billion dollars like
let's say
city coin becomes worth 10 billion well
then you're getting into a territory
where for many cities
uh you're you would not you would not
necessarily need to tax your own
residence because your income has
actually
eclipsed what the uh sort of tax
the tax budget and burden is on a yearly
basis so that's like a complete
inversion from what we're used to which
is like
you know government creation of debt tax
spend
all that this is like a much more
positive sum
um sort of thing so that's like um
that's like the model of startup
startup city city as a startup now the
other side of the
of the um sort of equation is the
stakeholders so you can have you know
people who live in the city people who
live out of the city who are hodlers
or just traders providing liquidity but
the reality is
there is now a market relationship with
the city that the users
can have so you know initially your ways
of voting
i'll give a few examples of how they how
they benefit so originally your ways of
voting
were you know vote with your ballot
which in which case like
half the time you're pretty pissed at
who gets elected and then even
if your your person does get elected
they don't always do everything you want
them to do
um to benefit your city and then the
other way is voting with your feet
very few people can actually vote with
their feet but we prove that it's very
possible in 2020 with remote working etc
um you know almost all my friends have
like moved from
whatever san francisco or new york to
miami or
to some other city and they're um you
know
they're essentially uh they're
essentially uh
that's the exit and the other the voices
ballot right now this third option
of voting with your coin i think is
really really useful um
because there will be hundreds
if not thousands of city coins in the
future you're going to be able to
move your assets from jurisdiction to
jurisdiction
and essentially have capital flight at
the speed of light
now that's a lot easier than waiting
four years two years
to vote in your bat with a ballot a lot
easier
than um picking up uprooting your family
moving to another place
you know not all cities are created
equal so like you know some people are
willing to
you know take a hit for the schools and
and and maybe the tax burden isn't so
much and they like the weather or
whatever
they stay put but they should have the
ability to
sort of win and help win uh in the
cities that
match sort of their ideology right
because if you're
if you're a token holder you're earning
yield as a function of merely
holding and locking your coins now
that's just
that's like a purely financial and sort
of voting
aspect of city coins and you're you're
also
um you're also going to be able to sort
of develop the city coins too so you can
imagine like proof of huddle
um you know access control to digital
and physical
applications locations um you can
imagine
and you know um so you can imagine
people betting
uh like you know voting essentially
voting on what they think is going to
happen in the future
uh you can have people actually voting
themselves within within like the
within the the actual uh within their
actual uh city coin group
and you can you can imagine like uh
you know atomic swaps like you know
transferring in and out
of different cities coins uh and using
decentralized exchanges
uh and just programming applications
that require usage of that
that cities city city city coin
that's what i think is interesting yeah
go ahead and so when you think through
that right
it sounds like the city um there's a way
to basically change the economics of a
city
uh and and to use kind of new technology
to uh to do that
uh it also seems like maybe there's
another side of this
uh that is almost like you could bet on
a city early
or you could bet on the safety of a city
staying relevant
uh and maybe even in some crazy way like
you could like short a city
uh which is like a little weird but but
uh potentially possible
and so is it fair to say that really
it's um
the city and the city is a proxy for
this local citizens because the city's
going to use that
revenue to to kind of make the city
better uh is kind of one
type of customer and then the second
type of customer is
individual investors or organizations
that are investors uh and that could be
local citizens or other people around
the world
got it okay and so let's talk through
if i'm sitting in that government seat
right so um
you know let's use miami as an example
uh right now
um you guys have miami coin uh
what is the evaluation that the mayor of
miami
uh a governor of the state etc would
make in terms of
uh what their options are so what are
the things that they could do and then
why would they do certain actions versus
other actions
yes i think the primary action the
primary decision that
um these municipalities need to make
initially
is whether they're going to claim their
uh reserved wallet
now mining city coins and
the reserved mining city coins can
happen prior to that
and and therefore their reserved wallet
will
be credited um money
ongoingly like 24 7 and essentially what
happens is
that bag gets so big it becomes a
fiduciary duty for the city to pick it
up
right so if you have 10 million dollars
just sitting on the sidelines and you're
not doing anything
your your citizens are going to get
pretty pissed that you're not using it
to um you know fix uh homelessness
or um you know recruit more crypto
startups or
you know beautify the city um you know
or
um or do what whatever you want to do
with it
the factor means most cities actually
have budgets that
are like right at the cusp of what they
can tax
and this provides this provides an
additional
revenue source for cities that was
previously not there before so instead
of the zero-sum
tax and spend sort of methodology
this is a much more positive some uh
sort of
way for cities to uh benefit from people
supporting the city and are they able to
take let's say there's 10 million
dollars sitting there in that wall they
claim the wallet
can actually go sell the tokens to
get the cash or or whatever
asset that they want yeah they can do
what it they can do with it whatever
they want so
they can they can um so they're going to
be earning stacks
and if they want to buy back their own
coin their own city coin which i think
is a very healthy thing to do
they can buy back their own coin and
they can just do that if they want to
they can liquidate into usd and just say
hey
um you know we want to keep crypto on
our balance sheet but we're willing to
like liquidate into usd ongoingly
and and we'll you know use this budget
for something the city controller can
decide
um or they can say hey this is a great
opportunity for more transparency we'd
like to
show you where we're sending this money
to so you can actually track the
payments in the blockchain
and i think um increasingly what you're
going to sorry increasingly what you're
going to see
are mayors operating in public and
financial controllers operating in
public
and having feedback with the community
and um
sort of like showing where the money is
going um and sort of optimizing for
um optimizing for people being bullish
on the city
like you were saying before you can you
can effectively um
short a city or go along a city like san
francisco is a city
that i think unfortunately is like kind
of being run into the ground
uh in in some ways and san francisco is
a great city
um but it's a city that could be doing a
lot better
so you could bet on the turnaround maybe
san francisco is trading on
10 cents on the dollar um based on what
you think it's going to do in the future
you think they're going to get their app
together
whereas and maybe miami coin you think
is just going to continue booming as
long as suarez is
uh sort of mayor and um you know there
might become a
time when it's overvalued and you want
to move into another city
uh like bitcoin beach or something you
know or or singapore or dubai or
whatever
but why is this the right time for this
now right one of the key parts of
technology kind of taking hold and
gaining adoption is just the right
timing of
of a market why do you think now is the
right time
yeah so i think that
i mean there's there's like a huge 30
000 foot view on this and then there's
like the
10-year view and i think if you
if you look at if you look at the united
states
i think when you talk to most people you
say hey i think the us is kind of like a
descending country
it's no longer on the ascent um which is
like an unfortunate
an unfortunate conversation to have of
course but most people will agree with
you
they'll say yeah that that's like a fact
that's true like essentially we're like
sun setting in a way
and i see like just within the united
states um
there's an opportunity for city states
to actually become more important than
than like the sort of top co the net
like the the whole nation
and and in part i think city coins
represent a way to almost like
buoy um buoy uh countries like the us
that might be on the descent uh and
accelerate countries
and celebrate accelerate cities that
uh essentially want to modernize uh you
know you're
you're already seeing um you're already
seeing like the
the playbook from el salvador and
paraguay and
south america which is by the way unlike
the same longitude lines as the us i
think it's like they're a great release
valve we've already seen the playbook
there
um where essentially they uh they
plug into like the bitcoin standard and
they
um they you know essentially try to
modernize their country
um through attracting like technology
technologists and crypto capitalists and
and you know some say like okay they
have nothing left to loot left to lose
so why don't they do it
i think they're actually just like the
first raindrops of a huge geopolitical
uh movement that's going to happen then
that is essentially going to be
where many cities and even countries
sort of move over to the crypto access
axis of uh
of of sort of capital as opposed to
the sort of fiat like usd or yuan or
whatever
um yeah so i think this is just like an
opportunity for opportunistic cities i
think they're going to benefit
tremendously from this and the ones that
move fastest might be not the ones that
you'd expect but they're
but the ones who are uh sort of most
opportunistic
you could have literally gone and worked
with anyone right
everyone from new york city to an el
salvador bitcoin beach
uh to tijuana to somewhere in asia
um but you chose miami what why miami uh
over kind of all the other places you
could have gone first
well one thing is
miami miami miami is incredibly
technologically progressive like
let's just like call it what it is you
know you have you have um
you know florida with low taxes you have
francis suarez and the rest of the gang
in miami
essentially rooting people on to move to
miami embracing embracing
uh embracing you know essentially
technology and capitalism and
and and all that and it's very diverse
city
it's not it's not just uh you know it's
not
uh it's it's not a super homogeneous
city there's a lot of heterogeneity
and the the culture is is a
is a is a vibrant one you know not it's
not a boring town that's for sure
um and it's sort of like a gateway to
south america too i think that's really
important
um and then the thing that that
one of the things that kind of tipped it
for me was like uh
was like um you know
san francisco was kind of this foil for
miami to grow
um in terms of like two poles on an
ideology
san francisco essentially and got
infected with like an exotoxic meme and
and and their uh their entire city is
sort of um
this their their entire city is on a
mission to
uh validate their ideology uh that is
like incongruent with reality
whereas like mayor suarez and you know
love him or hate him i'm very pro suarez
but lover hayden um he's actually
capturing
all these new customers and customers i
mean like
new citizens and new people visiting the
city and he's doing that by using sf as
a foil
like what's crazy to me is it's not even
clear that sf even like realizes they're
they're in a huge issue they're they're
in there
they're in a really bad place like i i
think they're actually
i think i think they still think that
everything's just going to be fine for
them when it's not actually
totally clear that that is going to be
the case um
so sf being a good foil for miami
honestly did
did impact um some some some of this and
i think
you know when you have a mayor that's
like willing to talk to you on twitter
it's like how
how can you not want to reward that
person uh for the work that
that he's doing you know like
essentially
when you well when you say you're pro
technology and
and and you're pro technologist and
you're gonna have a safe place for
or you know freedom to innovate you're
not gonna cast these people out
well the people that you're welcoming in
um are going to
reward you very much like they want to
help you and
tech is like an incredibly uh helpful
culture
like you know there's a lot there's a
lot of journalists that like to write
bad things about technologists and you
know no
no one is no one is morally 100 uh pure
like no one's a puritan um but
technology i i
worked in much of it at different
industries and like technology has been
most like positive some
uh you know helpful sort of culture i've
ever been in
um and i i think uh i think i think
suarez knows this and suarez
stands to benefit from it from it so we
wanna we wanna we wanna help them out
and if they help out this movement
they're gonna be unlocking the door to a
massive massive uh movement that is like
already well underway
one of the ideas that you've shared me
before that i think is fascinating is
this the idea of municipal
equity versus municipal debt maybe
elaborate on that a little bit and just
kind of explain what those two things
are
and the differences and kind of you know
um how people can kind of capitalize on
this framework
yeah so um a lot of people are familiar
with municipal debt
where um where uh a government will
like city government will um create you
know like 800 million or a billion
dollars worth of debt uh and then
they'll um sell it um for
you know low interest rate and then um
their taxpayers have to pay it back
right so there's very antagonistic
relationship between
their ability to effectively um you know
print money that they can spend
uh that later has to be raked you know
or has to be like you know taken out of
the hands of their citizens
um and the issue one of the issues is
like you know
the citizens don't even own that debt
they're not benefiting from the interest
rate they're like
how many how many miamians own miami
muni bonds
like very few it's mostly like you know
institutions and sovereigns or whatever
um and you know what
when there's good money be made it's
it's it's in those like large spreads
it's usually because
it can be because like a city is about
to go bk
and like go bankrupt um so that's not
that's not like uh
that's not like the sort of positive
some uh sort of
uh situation that a concept like
municipal equity
uh conceptually would would be so like
municipal equity is something where all
stakeholders
uh have a stake in success of the city
so
you can imagine like imagine if you have
nyc
coin and like there's a lot of people in
new york city that want to
that want to hold that coin because it's
it's bearing it's bearing a very healthy
interest rate
and the success of that city means that
not only
does their interest rate go up uh sort
of commensurately to the market cap
but also their their uh their holdings
go up and the city benefits from it as
well
so um you know i think a lot of people
feel detached from
their city in terms of ways they can
help and this is this is like um
this is one way where they can win with
the city and help
and help help you know help the city win
as well and
you know similar to how people have uh
ownership in a company
um you know this is like uh this is like
a sort of company
buying you know the idea of
cities is it fair to think of uh
maybe debt being um kind of an old
model for the way that a city would work
and equity
uh with new technology actually being
the way that cities in the future will
be financed
or do you think it's kind of a
coexistence where they'll both uh be
leveraged for different things
i think of that coexistence just like
you have you know cities that have um
you know i'm sorry you have companies
that have um
that have uh you know corporate debt and
and and all that i think i think it'll i
think it'll co-exist
but you know not all debt is bad
obviously but
you know you can get in trouble with
that and um and
you get in real trouble when you get in
real trouble when you realize that the
old paradigm
that people were living under before
which is one
of immobility where people didn't really
move from city to city very often
is completely out the window now like
2020
you really blew the lid off off of off
of of that
um off of that uh being the reality
right like
you know you're in new york city they
have some extremely small amount of
people paying like all the taxes in new
york city it's like
that one percent leaving new york city
decimates new york city so they can't
even afford to have those people leave
right and so they can get into some
pretty precarious situations if they're
you know they're taking out too much
debt or um you know their budgets are
too high
and i think um this is just like one
more tool for the governments
it's also kind of like a trojan horse
too like these governments are
essentially all gonna be getting bitcoin
because
when you're on stacks you also earn
bitcoin you can it's like a dual
yielding asset you
you have like they earn stacks and they
can lock those and earn more bitcoin and
same with the city coin holders
so you know it's like but when
when you think about how people approach
trying to like cryptofy cities they're
like
well you know uh let's try to get crypto
to be adopted for
you know payments in stores it's like
maybe nah like maybe maybe actually you
know cap tables are like pretty
pretty valuable and like and and they
might be like most valuable data
structure
that exists and you know cities can
actually use cap tables as
a tool to uh to uh sort of
um essentially get get more revenue
and and uh and have the ability for
people to interface with their
government on
on a more like real time basis as
opposed to every four years
and yeah um hoping this is like a very
positive
trojan horse hey guys what's going on
before we continue with this awesome
episode i want to quickly talk about our
sponsor kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app
you'll have your portfolio in your
pocket you can track your portfolio
see who the winners and losers are every
day track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
crack crackit's been a longtime
supporter of this show so to say thanks
it would mean the world to me if you
would go and download their new mobile
app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
yeah when you think about kind of the
structure that you're leveraging here
some people will say hey why don't you
just use bitcoin right why do you need
to
uh leverage stacks or or kind of the
miami coin or city coin structure
walk through maybe the pros and cons of
doing something like this with
uh just bitcoin versus kind of
leveraging the security of the bitcoin
blockchain
and then doing it kind of on this uh the
sidechain or kind of a layer two type
approach
yeah um yeah to be sure we are anchoring
into bitcoin
um and so bitcoin becomes more valuable
as a function
of more usage of things like city coins
that
that creates more demand um for block
space on bitcoin so
that's like check the box there um but
in terms of um
you know why don't you just try to get
bitcoin integrated into every city
every city's got its own ideology you
can view them like companies like
you wouldn't put you wouldn't put 500
companies in the same cap table because
they're all different companies
oregon and they have um you know they
have their own
employees that are that um that have a
stake in
uh in the success of those companies and
those various missions so you could have
you know you could have a you could have
a take like a city like sf in a city
like miami you think those
cities want to be on the same capital
well hell no like um
those cities won't be on their own cap
table and they want to live or die
based on based on you know how well the
markets um
you know appreciate their their their
sort of ideology and how they operate
now uh bitcoin is actually very useful
in terms of like a substrate
so you can view bitcoin like unix or
linux rather
like you have big companies that that
plug in to
plug into you know linux because they
know that the others can't really mess
with it it's like a digital no man's
land
i think bitcoin really is that right so
like
um i think it's good to like view
bitcoin as like the
as like the sort of digital no man's
land where all these different
uh cities can plug into and they know
that the substrate's not gonna change
it's like a low entropy carrier
and um and yeah the cities are just
represented with their own their own cap
tables
so you know people people people have
some
like essentially like trade they could
they can trade these cities based on
what's going on
and you wouldn't be able to do that if
it was all in the same quote-unquote cap
table which would be bitcoin that would
be like
you know kind of like defusing the whole
thing
there's this mining aspect obviously to
bitcoin but there's also
a mining aspect to uh the city coins
maybe describe
kind of what that means when you say
mining uh with these city coins and
and uh how does that work who benefits
yeah um so with bitcoin um
you know you mine with compute and
electricity and um
that proof of work is incredibly costly
but it's incredibly secure
and we don't really see a reason to
replicate proof of work
over again like bitcoin is good and so
what we what we
think should happen is just recycling
that proof of work uh so what we do is
we
you know take bitcoins that sort of
crystallize robot sweat
and throw it into another consensus
mechanism
and which is uh called proof of transfer
so this already happens as i mentioned
earlier uh from bitcoin into the stacks
blockchain so stacks is secured by
bitcoin
and then we take the uh the the
you know the um the fuel which is
the stacks token to then secure new
blockchains and new
uh uh and into mint uh tokens on new
smart contracts
so we're essentially generalizing that
uh proof of transfer
um where uh people have to
tran like the stacks they have to
transfer bitcoin in order to
uh in order to mine new stacks and then
they have to uh then sorry the holders
of the stocks tokens who temporarily
locked them
um have that bitcoin that was sent to be
that was sent via mining
transferred to them and so um
uh yeah so then as i mentioned earlier
we take that stacks
that use it to can essentially compete
to mine new city coins so you could have
like
you have like over 100 people or 100
miners
sending stacks into the uh into the
city coin smart contract from miami coin
and
uh who uh who
who wins that is uh is pseudo-random
it's like it's kind of random but it's
weighted based on
the amount that's been put in so if you
put in like 90 of all
of all the of all the sort of uh
money that's going into that into that
specific block you have a 90
chance of winning um the um the
block reward at the end of those 10
minutes
and when you think about this is this uh
individuals doing it
is this the local government doing it is
it a
kind of combination of everyone who's
actually uh kind of the ideal miner
the ideal market participant there yes
sir
uh definitely getting a lot of
institutions and individuals
interested i think cities will also do
it themselves
um i think there's a world where the
sort of archetype for who's mining
is um
also kind of like a trader because what
you can do is
you have a decision where when you mine
uh say you mine for like 100 blocks or
you're you're likely going to win some
blocks right
and when you win those blocks you'll
have you'll have uh
you'll have the value at which you
essentially mine those
those tokens for and the value that
those tokens are trading on
the market so you're able to arbitrage
on the market if you want like if you're
mining those tokens at a 10 discount
you might decide hey i want to like just
sell these tokens as i'm mining it
and just take that 10 net profit some
people are going to say ah
actually i don't want to do this what i
want to do is i want to hold on to these
honest
i want to stack them and earn more
bitcoin as a function
um so um i think you're gonna you're
gonna get like different architects
you'll have like city mining
institutions individuals traders like
individual hodlers and then traders
um and we'll see where we'll see where
it nets out
where do you go from here so you got
miami um and
kind of having uh getting that up and
running and talking to city officials
and kind of pushing it forward
uh is this uh let's go to 50 cities in
the next year does it go to two cities
uh kind of what does that roll out look
like and kind of what are the future
plans
uh we want to move very fast um we want
we want to let
my we want to let miami win like succeed
in the beginning
um but then fast follow with uh many
city coins
where the community is sort of voting on
which is which is coming next
um i love to see two years from now 200
city coins in existence trading and
you know dozens of them at uh over a
billion dollar valuation
um and you know maybe even some at over
10 billion
evaluation um but the more cities we can
create the more of a dynamic we can have
between the cities
um you know so people can people can
choose from menu of different cities
that they want to put in their portfolio
as opposed to
just being limited to a small handful or
just even one
um but i think it would be a mistake to
just like launch a thousand cities right
now
i think it'd be like a huge diffusion of
focus and um
the goal here is like make
make make miami like uh make make miami
uh very successful and then as soon as
it's very clear that miami success will
uh move on to the next cities that the
community uh decides
i don't know if you have an opinion but
do you think miami's gonna take the
wallet like they're gonna claim the
wallet
um i uh i hope so i think they're pretty
i think they're pretty progressive city
yeah it's uh it's fascinating to me to
to think about the game theory that goes
into
uh basically as the value grows inside
of a wallet um
do they actually take it or not i don't
know
i'd have to think through like why they
wouldn't take it right to some degree
i mean imagine imagine like thousands of
people
who hold miami coin and
are on twitter you know trying to get
miami to pick up the bag and who are
also
saying no we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna will this to happen right
like let's get miami coined over a
billion dollars valuation i think it's
over two billion dollars valuation
but that means that the cost to mine
miami coin will go up commensurate with
the market cap and therefore
their reserved wallet uh will be worth
enough
or it actually becomes a fiduciary duty
to pick up to pick up the bag so to
speak
um and it's really important that the
community
that the community um kind of works
together and
and and and helps uh make this happen
but
um i'm optimistic
yeah it's absolutely fascinating um how
can people get involved what what are
the ways that uh
somebody who's listening to this
watching this uh what can they do
uh yeah first follow mine city coins
uh minecoins on twitter and
uh sign up with your email at
citycoins.com
you'll get all sorts of announcements
and um
and like amas and you know and like ways
to vote on new cities and things like
that and
and um and um
you know if you want to mine miami coin
when it begins mining
uh which it looks like it looks like
it's slated for july
we'll see what happens but it looks like
looks like july and
there's a bunch of there'll be a bunch
of like tutorials and stuff for how you
can do that
um and so there's a bunch of content uh
being created right now
and but um i think in the future
there'll be like a kind of like a
playbook guidebook for do you want to
bring city coins to your city here's how
you do it here's how you talk to your
elected official
and here's how you get people voting on
it sort of thing but
focus is like laser eyed on miami
for the time being got it and when you
start to think about
um kind of the the maybe social aspect
of this
uh is it helpful for people to kind of
talk about it
with uh their local officials or or talk
to
other people in their community or it
does you really have to wait until
uh you kind of come to their city or
town first
uh i think it's helpful i think like the
more the the idea can spread and
socialize
better like this is a really good meme
it's like a very
it's a very positive name and it spreads
uh
it spreads pretty easily seemingly like
people seem to get the concept very
quickly
like way way quicker than they you know
get the concept of like smart contracts
or you know decentralized computing or
whatever people understand what cities
are
um and so um yeah spread this with with
your grandma spread this with
you know spread this to everyone you
know uh and get them signed up at
citycoins.com for sure
i love it uh before i let you go ask
everyone the same three questions and
you'll get to ask me one
uh most important book that you've ever
read
i mean i hate to be trite but um
probably to solve an individual
that's pretty good also like the bias of
communication by harold ennis is like
that's a that's a weird one
um but it's a good one um
what is that about uh it was written by
this like canadian
dude in like 1951 i love i like pretty
much only read books that are like about
the future that predict
feature well and have been validated
impression books
um and essentially about different forms
of communication so you have like
time bias communication like oral
tradition uh
or like the great pyramids and you have
like space bias communication which is
like
you know stone tablets or like papyrus
like can move far but maybe they don't
last very long
uh and sort of marrying these two forms
of communication
can allow for essentially like
prosperous civilizations to exist and
you know i think of like bitcoin as like
a time in space bias
method of communication and like a
perfect substrate to build sort of like
civilization
level software which is why i'm like i'm
it's weird to feel like uh like
contrarium like i feel like bitcoin's
already won as money but
i feel like it's like super undervalued
as like substrate that people can like
anchor into
um and um i'm looking forward to that
like catching on a lot more in this
decade
i think like i think bitcoin is
bitcoin's gonna evolve once more in this
decade as like a
kind of like a truth like a ledger of
truth over this deck yeah over this
decade and
you know city coins is just one way of
sort of anchoring into that that pieces
got it what do you what about the sleep
schedule uh my friends are at eight
sleep
i sleep you know five six hours now i
sleep eight or nine and i sleep on their
thermo-regulated bed
and i just turn it cold as hell like as
cold as it can go but pretty much i just
do that
uh it's been a game changer for me
what's your sleep schedule nice man
uh i i've been falling asleep at like 9
30 10 o'clock at night and like waking
up at 6 6 30
um i'm on on pacific standard time so
kind of wake up early
um but i i do turn the temperature down
to 60 degrees and just like put
you know i do like the austrians do
where like you know the swiss
you know just put on like a a big heavy
blanket
and i sleep really deeply that way it's
it's the best way to do it uh third
question and then you get to ask me one
is aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
uh you know if you're asking about ufos
i think that's just like i think that's
just like new physics you can
like replace little green men with new
physics um
aliens i don't know i think if you ask
me this question a year ago i'd say
definitely aliens exist
um um i haven't really
i don't have a reason to say they don't
exist but just kind of like re-ex
re-examining things i'm yeah
i i don't know like i i think in this
next this next like 100 years we're
going to learn a lot more about the
nature of reality
especially through the lens of physics
and um there may be a world there may be
a world where
um where um you know believing that
there's no aliens is actually
like besides like bacteria whatever is
not so crazy like
who knows i don't i don't know it's uh
it's a
wild wild world we live in my friend
what one question do you have for me to
uh to finish up
um how how many brothers do you actually
have
unlimited it's infinite literally we
just spawn more and more and more there
there's one queen pop that just gives
birth gives birth to all the
little pumps that that is my mother uh
no
there's uh there's five boys total uh
i am uh i'm the oldest and then my two
youngest brothers are on
twitter so three of us uh obviously plus
my wife and
and uh there's two brothers that
actually have twitter accounts
but uh they are uh pseudonymous and uh
they're not really interested in uh
revealing themselves but one day maybe i
could
i can get them to start participating in
the fun
they should stay pseudonymous that is
like definitely the go-to these days
like
separate your working name from your
real name yeah
well that's what they've done so far and
uh they just kind of hide out in the
shadows you know and uh follow along but
no one knows they're there
nice and you're you're in you're in
miami now right i
am how how how are you liking it
i love it i'm just i always describe you
i'm just happier
like it's a simple way to just describe
everything all rolled up in one which is
just
literally i'm happier so i'm not i'm not
leaving
that's amazing uh are you gonna mind
miami coin
uh potentially yeah let's get it live
first
[Music]
right all right where can we send people
you said at mine city coins on twitter
and then citycoins.co that's right yeah
nailed it okay and where can people
follow you on twitter
uh i'm patrick w stanley
patrick w stanley it's long but awesome
man well listen thank you so much for
doing this
i think this is a super interesting
concept and uh if uh
the mayor of miami or somebody else in
another city ends up kind of embracing
this i think that it could be pretty
interesting seeing this idea of
municipal equity versus municipal debt
so i appreciate you coming on explaining
it to us and we'll have to do it again
in the future as things progress
yeah suarez if you're listening which i
know you are
we can't wait to help you and thanks for
being a great mayor